Wives. Do not do this to your husbands.
I was at the thrift store yesterday with my husband,
and we were just shopping around,
looking at all the cool stuff.
This lady comes up to me and she goes,
what is this called?
Holding up a spatula?
And I said, oh,
well, that's a spatula.
And she goes,
see, I told him.
I told him it was a spatula,
not a pancake flipper.
And you could tell that her husband was sheepish,
was walking away,
did not wanna be part of this conversation at all.
And I thought to myself, you know,
this doesn't prove him wrong.
This just proves that you're disrespectful
not only in public to completely random strangers,
but you're also disrespectful,
most likely in your home as well.
Her attitude towards him was not a reflection on him
and what he thought this thing was called.
It was a reflection on her
and how contentious and brash and loud she was being.
I guarantee you
her husband felt extremely disrespected
and extremely emasculated.
So do not do this to your husband's.
It does not come off well.